foreign
[Music]
thanks for coming to my talk uh really
excited to kind of peel back the
curtains a little bit on Cordo and show
it off to the world for some of the
first times my name is Tom Mock and if
you want to follow along with these
slides you can do so at rstd.io
cordo-curious
so really for the longest time and why
I'm so excited about talking about it
now is that for the longest time we
weren't talking about Cordo we were kind
of working on it behind the scenes
getting things ready for that first
stable release
in April this year we actually did our
first kind of Beta release or some of
the like initial soft release uh Allison
Hill wrote up this great talk or great
blog post called we don't talk about
Cordo until now Allison was one of the
folks who used to work with the
development team before she moved over
to Voltron data and it just really kind
of opened the floodgates to people
hearing about Cordo started talking a
little bit on Twitter or generally just
generating some hubbub
for the most part people were really
excited you know they're just like oh I
hear about quarto let me try it out I
really like it so Kelly said you know
she stayed up all night switching over
her marked on materials over to Corto
and her kind of takeaway was it's pretty
rad my dudes I like it so she's enjoying
it
and there's even some excitement in the
python community so if you're familiar
with Jeremy Howard or the NB Dev team or
fast.iai they're actually moving some of
their work over into quarto and using
that along with Jupiter notebooks in
fact hamal is going to be talking about
that tomorrow in his talk talking about
the Next Generation version of nbdev
now while there's a lot of excitement in
both the r and the python Community
there was also people who had a few more
questions and I think that's where a lot
of y'all are y'all are the chordo
curious and you've come to my talk to
hear a little bit about what is Cordo
why should I care what's different about
it what's going on with our markdown and
all of that
first off don't worry our markdown's not
going away uh is we're still going to
maintain it if bug fixes happen we'll
definitely fix them
ultimately the question that people have
is when when can I switch to Cordo when
is it ready is it stable you know what
what's going on with it
Soul Plane will answer that question by
saying what is Cordo so Cordo is the
next Generation version of our markdown
for everyone and that everyone kind of
has an asterisk to it in terms of not
six billion people or whatever's around
the world but for really any data
science language or any future language
as JJ talked about in his keynote this
morning we want to build a hundred year
company and while that today might mean
working in R and Python and Julia and
JavaScript and other languages in the
future we want kind of a language
agnostic tool that can work with
anything anything that comes popular in
the future
to make it a bit more clinical instead
of just saying the next generation of
our markdown quarto if we Define it is
an open source scientific and Technical
publishing system built on pandok so
pandok is a command line tool that's
also used by our markdown so again
there's going to be a lot of familiarity
as we go through these slides and we'll
build up a mental model of how Corto is
a little bit different than our markdown
and some of the improvements
quarto itself is a command line
interface or what's called a CLI so you
can access Cordo via your terminal
whether in our studio or any text editor
or any terminal on your computer in this
example I'm just calling Cordo dash dash
help to see what can I do with Cordo
once I've installed it on my machine
it'll print out something like this and
I've abbreviated it so we can see the
slides nice and big but the commands
here that we're looking at are I can use
quarter render to render documents from
the plain text format out to say HTML or
PDF or to a website
I can use quarto preview which will
actually render the document and then
maintain a background web server so as I
make changes it shows those in real time
on the actual rendered output
and because it's a publishing system I
can not only render it locally but I can
publish it to the web places like GitHub
Pages or netlify or something else we'll
talk about in the future called quarto
pubs
to really kind of build up our mental
motto though and help differentiate a
little bit between our markdown and
quarto we need to kind of talk about
what our markdown is and what is
happening behind the scenes
when you use our markdown in your daily
work you're probably just thinking oh
yeah I open up an R markdown inside our
studio type some code Type some text and
then I render it and I get something
beautiful out
behind the scenes are things that are
happening here in the middle is actually
a little bit of kind of magic it's not
real magic it's code but it's things
that are happening as intermediary steps
so when you render your arm mark down
the r code is evaluated by a package
called Knitter that'll evaluate your
code generate Graphics generate tables
embed HTML widgets and all the other
magic that you're building
this generates an intermediary markdown
file or a DOT MD file that is then
passed to pandok which actually converts
a plain text MD into something like a
report so a Word document a PDF report
or HTML page or a presentation just like
the presentation I'm giving today
something in HTML or a more complex
project like a website or a book
so this process is great and it's been
around for almost 10 years you know
knitter's a old package it's robust
we've been using a long time
something to note though is that it has
this hard dependency on R so to use our
markdown whether you're using r or other
languages you have to have R you have to
have Knitter you have to knock it down
and some of the formatting or
pre-processing that occurs so the
document actually occurs with literal R
code written in the r markdown package
for Cordo we have a similar diagram and
for some of you if you're not looking
closely this might look like the exact
same workflow but there's a few
differences we'll note number one rather
than using a DOT rmd I'm now using a qmd
or a quarto markdown document it's going
to feel almost identical to our markdown
which is great
and we're still using Knitter so Knitter
will evaluate our R code from our qmd
generate an intermediary markdown file
but now we have another word added to
pandok we have pandok with Lua filters
so we've moved any pre-processing or
post-processing into quarto that command
line interface or to affect them with
pandok rather than having to call them
from r
what this does is still allows us to
create the same reports presentations
and projects that are available but we
don't have to have R in the system to
use this you could use quarto on a fresh
computer and not have R anywhere in it
and just render markdown as opposed to
code so people could use it for
scientific communication without
actually having to execute code
but because again we're trying to become
this company that is building for all of
data science and building for scientific
Communication in general we want to do
more than just evaluate for our code
so quarto also extends to other
languages so quarto can now use Jupiter
and Jupiter kernels as the engine rather
than just R and Knitter so you can
imagine Jupiter kernels include things
like Julia or python we also have
JavaScript you can execute via Corto so
you have this availability of not just
being limited to R but collaborating
with other people in python or if you're
a python Dev yourself also using python
within your quarto documents and again
the output that you're creating is not
any different you're just using a
different engine because you're using a
different programming language
and if I'm using python all I have to
have is python on my system if I'm using
Julia all I have to have is Julie on my
system and I can switch between them if
I wanted to without having to change the
overall document
for some other people who are working
with say Julia or python or familiar
with Jupiter they don't want to use a
plain text format they might not even
use our studio they want to use Jupiter
notebooks or Jupiter lab as their
environment and that's possible too so
you can use a literal.i python notebook
or what's called a jupyter notebook and
whether using Julia or python you can
execute code inside of that and with
essentially the same rendering process
create the exact same output
so whether using this plain text qmd or
a more complex kind of binary format
like Jupiter all of those can create the
same presentations the same reports and
the same projects that you want to
create
if we think of what qmd looks like
a little bit to what you're kind of
working mental model of say in our
markdown document
we have the yaml header or the metadata
that says do this with my document so
format HTML create an HTML static page
here we have side by side choice of
choosing an engine for Knitter in r or
say choosing an engine of Jupiter or a
Python 3 or Julia to execute that code
and again you're executing it natively
you're not wrapping it in our code or
wrapping it in Python execute the
Opposites you're just evaluating it in
its normal engine
you can then write some code so we have
here a group by summarize with empty
cars and D plier and then in a python
Library called Suba both of which look
relatively similar but one's evaluating
purely in R and one purely in Python
then we have a bunch of text or markdown
that we're using to you know create the
actual uh Pros or the text inside the
document you can see this spans both
columns there's no difference in the
markdown you're writing or the way that
you use chordo to kind of typeset your
document that is the same between any
language you're using
so again whether you're using r or
python or Jupiter or whatever else you
can write these documents and again get
the exact same output whether you're
changing your engine or not cool so we
got a plain text format it looks kind of
similar to our markdown I'm still not
sold what's the difference so let's talk
about that
number one Cordo is one install what we
call batteries included so when you
actually install the latest version of
our studio that was released on Monday
quarto is just there it's installed with
our studio so as soon as you download
the newest version of our studio or
update it in the future you have access
to quarto you don't have to install
anything else you can just start using
it you would need an engine if you
wanted to use R then you install R if
you want to use Julia install Julia or
python you install python but for at
least our studio users it's baked into
using it so great it's always around and
you never really have to think about it
or have to update your packages it's
just there
the other half of that battery is
included though is that there's a whole
bunch of formats that have been created
over the past you know five or ten years
of our markdown so you have your basic
formats like HTML documents or Word
documents PDF different presentations
like this that are made in reveal.js or
even Advanced layout like distill that's
several different our markdown packages
in quarto it's just all there that one
install of Cordo brings along all the
different formats and it also includes
the even more complex format so things
like websites or blogs or books or
interactive documents all of that can
also be done just with the one install
of Cordo so rather than having to manage
a bunch of different our markdown
ecosystems that were developed at
different times and might have different
syntax you have batteries included one
install with the shared syntax
there's still a few things we want to
add into quarto to match full parity
with our markdown specifically Flex
dashboard is one of the ones that we're
really passionate about adding quickly
and that's a way of creating dashboards
with Cordo as well as the older version
of flex dashboard in our markdown
great so it's a little bit easier to
install it might even be installed
automatically for you
the other part is that you want to stay
in the comfort of your own workspace if
I ask you to like bake a cake and I told
you go do it in the corporate kitchen
here it might be really hard versus
going to your own home and baking it at
your own kitchen table probably a bit
easier
similarly with Cordo you get to choose
and stay within the comfort of your own
workspace so you can obviously use
inside our studio it's preambled there
it's going to again feel almost
identical or markdown so all of that
work you've done to learn our markdown
or if you're learning our markdown
recorder for the first time learning
Cordo can be applied within the r
markdown or sorry within the r Studio
ecosystem
you still have a button for render you
don't have to go and use the CLI but
it's still there for you and it's
actually embedded into different
functions that are available through our
studio
but again when you say oh I want to
collaborate with my my colleague or my
friend and they're saying oh I work in
Julia and I don't really like using our
studio like that's not the editor I want
to use or I'm a python Dev and I really
want to work in a Jupiter notebook
Cordo works just as well in a Jupiter
notebook so you can use that as your
editor if you want to
again we've got kind of on the left this
idea of that's the IPython notebook
you're working in you're writing pure
normal Jupiter notebook code the only
thing that's different is at the top you
now have a raw chunk with the yaml
that's defining what's the format what
do you want to affect and then on the
right you have a quarter preview so when
you're typing and saving it'll actually
re-render and show the output instantly
as it builds it out
and again maybe you don't like using
Jupiter maybe that's not what you're
wanting to look at maybe you use vs code
as your editor and you're really
passionate about that because you also
work and say JavaScript or other
languages
you we actually developed a quarter
extension for vs code so you get this
Rich interactive experience both in like
a notebook format so using again a plain
qmd as opposed to a jupyter notebook
and you can also do quarto preview and
get that real-time output as well
so whatever editor you want or whatever
editor you have to collaborate with your
colleagues on they can stay in the
comfort of their own workspace you can
stay in your own comfortable workspace
and you can still collaborate across a
document with a shared syntax
the other part of what building for our
studio and building for other editors
like vs code is we have things like Rich
autocompletion which wasn't always
available and is something that's added
in quarto
so I'm editing a document I might
remember oh yeah I'm using format HTML
but what else can I do here and if I
click control space inside our studio or
vs code it'll actually pull up all the
options that are possible almost like
with our code inside the editor you can
hover over it and see what does this
function actually do
that works in yaml and it also works in
chunk options again there's dozens of
Chunk options you can do and while some
of them are very Niche you're not going
to use them all the time those are very
powerful for knowing exactly what you
need to do and seeing like oh I need to
change figures I just start typing
figures and no autocomplete to what's
available
and again whether you're working in
python or r or our studio or vs code
this is available for you
great so we've got some uh Auto
completion in Python and R maybe we want
to talk more about formats and we want
to get excited about that so this is
actually an HTML widget you'll notice
that I'm pulling it over this is
actually where we are today so we're at
the National Harbor I can click on this
and it says we're here together
so I can drag that over a little bit
it'll load the internet's a bit bad in
here so it's not loaded all the way but
importantly you can see I'm actually
interacting with it with our code
so you can do shiny you can do HTML
Widgets or other things you've built and
put those into Cordo and in python or
your python colleagues they can also
embed what are called Jupiter widgets so
similarly you have the ability to create
interactivity on the client side both
with python and with our within a single
quarter document or in separate quarter
documents
another part of interactivity that
quarto adds though is beyond just using
R and python it even embeds a version of
JavaScript called observable JavaScript
this is an extension to vanilla
JavaScript created by Mike Bostock who's
also the author of D3 that might be one
you're more familiar with than the
JavaScript land
and now we have a reactive JavaScript
library that might look to you like a
little bit like shiny you know I have
the ability to create and interact with
different tags and it will actually
change the graphic or I can do things
like filter the data to have specific
build links for this Penguins data set
and again this is baked into quarto so
you don't have to install another thing
this interactivity is added for the
document itself
so we've got this kind of idea of the
generativity different editors we can
also kind of unify a lot of the syntax
that was created across years of our
markdown
so again this is next in our markdown
our markdown itself is not being
uninstalled from the web and removed
from the internet we're still
maintaining it we'll fix any bugs but
our new Devil uh Dev kind of effort is
going to go towards Cordo and to Knitter
so Knitter will still power you know our
markdown still power Cordo but we're
focusing on quarto as this next
generation of uh kind of data science
and Technical science communication
you might be asking yourself okay well
I've got a lot of old r markdowns that I
want to use so for some of you keep
using them we're still going to maintain
our markdown you don't have to switch if
you don't want to you can keep using it
but Cordo can actually render our
markdown documents so you can take your
existing our markdown documents and
render them over to whatever format you
want via quarto so whether you're
staying in our markdown or switching
them over you can still render them out
and in fact this unification of
different formats let's say we were
trying to render to HTML into PDF for
HTML we use things like CSS and raw HTML
for PDF we're going to be using latex
and other things like that
normally you'd have to write a lot of
manual code in there to convert between
them but for this document I'm not
writing any CSS or any latex I'm only
using quarto and I can create a nicely
typed set document like this it's got a
picture in the sidebar it's got a table
of contents and all sorts of other
footnotes and things
that documented PDF looks almost
identical you're obviously constrained
to what PDF can do so you don't have
hover text and you don't have uh the
same type of interactivity as HTML but
without having to write anything else
besides quarto code or quarto markdown
I'm able to generate these two very well
typeset documents from a single source
so single Source publishing for this
and again cordo's extended for other
languages so this type setting and all
the different things it brings are made
with Lua filters rather than an r
package so things that people write in
Python language and in r or in Julia are
cross-language and cross format
compatible
so we're meeting these users in their
native language so when you are
collaborating you're not fighting with
each other but you're merging around a
common syntax
those people might ask well what to do
about my existing IPython notebooks you
know I don't want to get rid of them the
answer is essentially the same I can
quarter render any IPython notebook and
send it over to the format the only
difference is an IPython notebook might
actually store computation inside of it
so you can either tell Cordo hey take
this document and render it top to
bottom or using the embedded execution
just format it out to something else or
change the format to the final output
and in fact Cordo has a helper tool to
allow you to convert between a plain
text qmd and an IPython notebook itself
so you can swap back and forth whether
using IPython notebooks or Cordo without
having to change the source code you can
actually convert back and forth between
them
you can also extend Cordo so we have
things like short code so if you wanted
to add something in to the open source
quarter you could use a shortcode like
this that will insert things like fun
awesome icons
or you can add filters that will
actually change the overall appearance
of a document and again this is not
limited to any language so any
extensions that you write in a python
world work in R and anything in R Works
in Python
you can also add entirely new formats so
maybe you want to create a format for
your company you can create your own
cool company format for reveal.js
so these extensions allow you to go
further with quarto as we move forward
and add more things
and then lastly I mentioned this idea of
quarto pubs so Cordo can actually
publish the thing you just rendered to
the internet
so you can publish to GitHub or to
netlify our studio connect but we're now
announcing that Cordo pubs exist it's a
free resource that allows you to publish
anything you create locally and put that
out on the web at a URL you choose and
manage all of your documents that you're
publishing out
so this is very exciting I would
recommend signing up quickly to go grab
your preferred username and you can use
that
the last part I'll say is again you can
use Cordo in rstudio Connect and our
studio workbench already so if you do
have those products available for you we
have some examples of using them and
you're welcome to go check them out
and with that we're getting close to the
end of the talk so I want to give a
shout out to the entire Cordo Dev team
quarter was crafted with love and care
by the same team that works on quarter
in our markdown and you can contribute
yourself if you want to contribute
whether an extension or to the quarto
CLI itself
I've got a summary of the talks that are
available and other things coming up and
some takeaways with the batteries
included the shared syntax the ability
to choose your editor and your language
and the fact that our markdown is not
going anywhere we're still maintaining
it we're going to be building in a lot
of our new features into Cordo
with that thank you for your time I'm
happy to take questions after the fact
down in the lounge or you can reach out
to me on Twitter thank you and have a
great and safe conference
thank you